as protests continue across the nation
thousands of people made their way to
historic West Las Vegas for a different
sort of event tonight thank you for
joining us at 11:00 i'm bryan loftus and
I'm Denise fel des it was called the we
deserved to live rally and it happy
happened at kianga you Sookie palacio
Park which used to be known as Doolittle
Park 8 News Now reporter Joe Moller is
there with more on tonight's event Joe
good evening you too yeah this event
wrapped up around 9 o'clock just a few
hours ago this was different than the
protest we've covered throughout the
week this was about a conversation
having conversation and finding
solutions to the problems now the
organizer did not call this a protest
today the goal was to stand up against
police brutality and systemic racism in
our country Reverend Sanders who created
the event even talked about possible
legislation to help hold law enforcement
accountable when it comes to the use of
force he said this wasn't the first step
in finding solutions and it won't be the
last speakers talked for few hours and
some petitions were circulating a vigil
was also held for George Floyd and
others who have lost their lives 1
speaker we also talked to said George
Floyd changed the world and has a lot
more people noticing the problems our
country faces overall this event was
very peaceful the organizer says this
whole event will hopefully unify the
community reporting live in historic
West Las Vegas Joe Moller 8 news now